this program is brought to you by Emory
University hello welcome friends family
and the BB a class of 2011 thank you so
much for coming in today from all over
to help us celebrate our graduation
today is truly an incredible day and I'm
honored to be a part of the ceremony I'd
like to offer a quick apology to my
mother it doesn't look like i'm going to
be a doctor after all
I think when I said I was coming to
Emory there was still hope but alas
you've gotta go out of business school
student for a son so what does it mean
to be a boys what a business school
student well in case you've missed the
t-shirts signs emails posters sky
writings invisible toolboxes and
underwear according to businessweek were
ranked number three in the nation
it means we've all survived bila with
burdette and continued our addiction to
diet coke you think it's a coincidence
that she places the label towards us I
hear she makes fifty dollars a class and
product placement alone it is business
school after all and finally it means we
spent the past two years being primed
and prepped to go into the world of
business and beyond we've had our
resumes edited and edited and edited and
edited again we've networked sober and
less than sober Thank You kegs and can
now basically write our own books on
case based interviews but before we go
off to become CEOs of major corporation
and corporations and donate building
spectacles wetta I'd like to make I'd
like to take a moment to present what i
like to call decisions decisions the
biggest decisions we've made a Coy's
wetta and what better way to do that
than through interpretive dance
I'll stick to what I know and that of
course is PowerPoint
so yes I know I skipped the agenda bar
sorry Epstein I'll blame it on
senioritis you know when you go to
college one of the things that I grew to
appreciate was the freedom of choice and
here at kawada there are a lot of
important decisions we've made perhaps
the most important being your choice of
concentration we have five major
concentrations here at quizzo etta
marketing finance om accounting and I
somme but which to choose so I'd like to
maybe run through what these are all
about are you under 5 to and from New
York perhaps you'd be interested in
accounting
do you enjoy coloring and talking about
apple products perhaps the marketing
concentration can teach you all you need
to know do you dream of someday being
overworked and overpaid would you
sacrifice a firstborn to work at Goldman
the finance curriculum the finance
curriculum has the breadth and depth to
get you there someday of course if you'd
like to spend the rest of your life
explaining to people what a consultant
is ONN can make it happen and lastly
there's I some I don't really know what
you guys do but I'm sure you do it well
and we will use it someday of course
once you've headed down a certain path
there's always the choice of what
teachers you should choose to have you
know as you've seen today we're so
fortunate Coy's wedded to have
world-class faculty I'd like to
highlight a couple from Professor reshma
Shaw I learned that great things really
do come in short I mean small extremely
talented packages and from Professor
writer and strategy I learned the magic
words of synergy and Porter's five
forces trust me people it works every
time and for professor Clifton green I
learned about cocaine
and its similarities to debt of course
making the good times better and the bad
times worse you know we've had the most
accessible successful and experienced
faculty and whether you're learning T
accounts or macros you're learning them
well we've even have terrific support
through the BB a program for example I'm
sure we all appreciate the last minute
confidence boost from leap a socal our
business school librarian is quoting why
the hell haven't you check data monitor
yet or the always helpful reminder that
you've been avoiding gym for the past
three years and it's time to either take
yoga go on the b school ski trip or in
my case both only in business school do
you have the choice between spending a
semester jogging with freshman or
spending a weekend coasting down a
gently sloping hill in North Carolina
and watching magnificent works of films
such as piranha 3d
and then of course there's the study
abroad decision would you choose to
spend a semester struggling at goizueta
or surfing in Bali and attempting to
pass all your classes
it's
it's tough choices like these that have
built us up to be effective business
leaders of the future ironically it's
not the seemingly big decisions of
concentration to be or what classes to
take that can make you or break you but
rather who to work with that can make
all the difference of course there's
little you can do when assigned a group
but pray that you get the kid at the
smart kid in class that says all the
right things but when it comes to the
great fortune of picking your own group
be careful what you wish for I can
attest as an employee second semester
senior that I am someone to avoid as
we've all been
as you can see in this chart that I've
mathematically and scientifically
created the sweet spot of group members
lies in juniors with internships well
they no longer have the pressure of
interviewing they still care enough
about their grades and have no idea what
they'll be doing for the rest of their
lives some of us on the other hand did
and we had the great fortune of
practicing what i like to call upper
management skills
the least of which include included
showing up late to meetings voicing
unasked-for opinions and leaving the
poor juniors in my group to do all the
work I'm apologize if any of you are in
the room but remember what I told you do
a good job and I might employ you
someday
but of course there are students more
useless than I but I won't get into that
now
when thinking about decisions there was
one decision that I constantly k that it
constantly came up that I still tend to
lose sleep over no it wasn't what
internship to apply for or what poor
alumni would have to talk to me next
about a career in marketing no it was
the daily question at einsteins what do
you have cash or credit not to go off on
a tangent but has anyone else ever been
more stressed ordering a bagel I can't
decide what was who is more stressful
teachers or salmon Einsteins Sam we love
you you do a great job but we cannot
stand your cheeriness at nine thirty in
the morning before we've had our coffee
cards punched and also to the ladies of
Einstein's when our food is ready
there's no need to shout toasted sesame
bagel toasted sesame bagel we know we
ordered it we'll be right there in a
second to get it we promise okay sorry
about that back on track
you know outside of the classroom the
opportunities to exercise our
decision-making only grow I now
understand the Arts in our degree is
that's truly what the networking process
is all about fortunately the b school
has our back there too well we may not
always be ready for the three word
response to the two page email that
we've sent to a company or an alumni
we've been given all the tools necessary
to reach out and grab the opportunities
presented to us except of course for the
understanding of what the mean of what
the phrase reply all means why did we do
that so much um you know as I look out
at all of you now I'm excited to see
what will become and to take advantage
of each and every one of you you know
you never know you might need to stay in
touch with and I'm looking at you
Natasha la colony again Tiffany hon Eric
Ward Sonia sawhney Julia Freeling
mentioned you guys you all know me a
favor to receive at elite you're welcome
and please accept my linkedin request
after the ceremony so today as we look
beyond the lush green steps of the
courtyard towards our ever looming fate
in the world I like to think that we've
had the chance to control our own
destinies and make choices that we can
be proud of or come to think of it Thank
You Libby for filling out those forms
that outline every course professor in
section we would take for the next four
years I'm making us think like we made
on our own choices
I hope you can look back on the
decisions that you've made and be proud
this is an exciting time in our lives as
we go out and make decisions no longer
just for ourselves but for families
company's clients and more on Monday
will no longer be be be be be a students
but enter the world of being be ba alam
and yes Andy you can recruit at our
companies the past four years have been
a blast whether it be at kegs chillin by
the pool or working until two a.m. on
friday on our ops cases or maybe not all
of it was the best congratulations and
please remember the next time you buy a
diet coke let the register know that
Allison Burdette sent you she still has
two kids to put through college oh and
one more slide happy Mother's Day to all
the mothers mom sorry I'm not a doctor
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University